[Music]
foreign
if you think Pandora is a paradise then
clearly you haven't been paying
attention there are countless ways that
you as a human would die horrific depths
in the strange alien Moon so here are 15
different things that will kill you in
Avatar's Pandora let's get to it
firstly the toxic atmosphere it is a
mixture of nitrogen oxygen 18 carbon
dioxide 5.5 Xenon methane and one
percent hydrogen sulfide and it is about
20 denser than Earth's atmosphere the
high concentration of carbon dioxide
makes it poisonous to humans rendering
you unconscious in about 20 seconds and
causing death in about 4 minutes also
the one percent hydrogen sulfide means
it's things like rotten eggs so it's a
shitty death
number two if you survive that stench
then you will definitely be hunted by a
thanatore which is an apex predator of
the land it is 2.4 meters or 8 feet tall
and even the indigenous Navi are prey to
it so you a slow human with distinct
scent and that you give off will Attract
it as fast as a moth to a flame don't
worry this will be a quick death if it
catches you your head will be better
enough in a Split Second
so if you somehow evade this tiger of
Pandora then you will have to deal with
the Viper wolf one of them is a big risk
it can grow to be the size of a leopard
or a small tiger you could probably
fight it off with a shopping tool or a
spear let's say but if stopped by a pack
of these Viper wolves you would have
nowhere else to go but try to climb up a
tree they are faster than you they have
most stamina than you and especially as
a pack
number four Anyway by All Odds you
managed to climb up a tree and then wait
them out then you would probably have to
get down anyway they would get bored
they would leave you would have to come
down again make a fire and find food for
sustenance if you fall asleep or stay
lazy for a moment then you might get
crushed by a stampede of 6.5 meters or
22 feet tall titano tears animals the
height of two African elephants one on
top of another number five okay the
forest would not be such a good place
for you nowhere far to Sea and to assess
your danger levels or risks you decide
to come out to the open at first it
seems Serene with a lot of stern bees
and dire horses all herbivores out in
the open but the skies above pains a
different picture
forests and modern banshees which are
carnivorous and turbops which are like
the kings of the Skies like eagles will
Cruise in the open air looking for weak
prey and there you are a swift dive and
a swoop and you're carried off into the
winds you're just basically bird feet
number six okay now somehow you find a
rock or a Lone Tree to hide from the
flying animals the thick grass of
Pandora will not only hide you but also
deadly predators of the open Plains yeah
Slingers they are one of the fastest
land carnivores on Pandora as fast or
even faster than cheetahs if it catches
you it will since you're slow it will
inject a powerful neurotoxin paralyzing
your entire body before eating you alive
number seven now you might think if only
you would land or be let off in a
Paradise Island like the metcalina Clans
yes it would be a change of pace there
would be no big predators on the islands
but how long can you stay on it without
being tempted to go swimming in these
Open Seas do it and you will be
instantly swallowed by an akula or a
naluza creatures that are as fast
underwater as Horses are on land
number eight even the shallow Seas near
the beach will not give you much respite
animals that seem to look like gigantic
50 feet long flying fish with a head of
a crocodile will appear right out of the
water skimming the surface of the ocean
at speeds of over 90 kilometers per hour
or almost 60 miles an hour a bite from
these skim Rings will snap you in half
you'd either die due to shock or being
bled out to death or drowned it's your
pick
number nine coming back to the forest
are especially the swamps Thanatos or
viperwolves will not Venture into the
wetlands and you can easily dive inside
the shallow water to hide from banshees
so you might feel more safer there but
there is another problem this is home to
a multitude of parasites that will most
definitely latch onto you and slowly eat
you from the inside or attach to your
body and the secretions they give off
will most probably be venomous to the
human blood therefore ending you in a
slow agonizing death
number 10 then there is the possibility
of being swarmed there by a flurry of
sting bats these are small foul-tempered
aerial Predators with a highly developed
navigational system not small in human
terms as their wingspan is over 10 feet
wide so one of them usually feeds on
small prey like rodents or Lizards or
insects but a lot of them will swarm
with other sting bats against larger
prey such as the hexaped which is an
animal still bigger than you number 11
even plants in Pandora will kill you if
you come into contact with a poisonous
species I mean it wouldn't be stupidity
but more of being unlucky so if plants
on Earth here in our planet have
developed diverse kinds of defense
mechanisms to ward off herbivorous
animals like poisonous things thorns and
all of that Pandora with its alien
nature will definitely have more deadly
toxins on plants that can kill paralyze
or at least give you a bad rash
number 12 then there are the creepy
crawlies alien insects like the
arachnoid and the Hellfire wasps that
can sting you to death if they are
spooked or if you come too close to a
hive well a single Hellfire wasp
although rarely lethal to humans are
believed to attack as a swarm and near a
hive that would ultimately result in
fatality
arachnoids Venom is psychoactive to a
larger Navi but deadly to a smaller
human
number 13 so it seems that there are no
places to go without being stopped
hunted stung swung or otherwise one
might think okay a watering hole has a
sanctuary like mughley The Jungle Book
it would be a sanctuary from deadly
beasts but no not in this planet even in
such places there are monsters like the
shop to lizards that will spit a deadly
venom from a distance right into your
eyes and then paralyze you and fit on
you like a pack of rabbit Komodo dragons
number 14. so okay of course you're a
human in Pandora and what do you think
will hunt you the most not for food or
sport but you are seen as an enemy
referred to as the sky people the navi
that humans have slain and killed will
pick up your presence whether in the
forest grasslands oceans or Wetlands you
will not see your death coming just a
shock and an arrow right through your
chest
15. and lastly Against All Odds you
would find refuge in an abandoned RDA
Selman or you would make your own for
argument's sake let's say all seems safe
until sickness kicks in why because
there is a high probability of being
infected by unknown pathogens alien
viruses bacteria and other microbes that
your body have no immune response to
just one type will take you to AWA with
150 degrees fever
so Pandora isn't a paradise at all but
hell to a human pick your favorite way
to die and meet Eva so I hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam